hey guys so we're here in london for the
college of european championships and
i'm pretty excited we're about to do a
little interview here with graham hey do
you want to be my video yeah i'd love
that hi hi everybody so what are we
doing today uh we're gonna shoot some
intros and some footage for the college
at european championships
so yeah we're here in london it's pretty
exciting um that's all i have to say
right now
see you later
so before we head into the tournament i
kind of got to go check out build-a-bear
because i went to disney the other day
and i saw that they had camo
build-a-bears
and i kind of need
[Music]
them both of them
him up and get him some accessories
i think he needs a leather jacket like
mommy
do we want to go with like the yeah do
matching
the digital camo that's how you dressed
on the first day we were here that's
true
[Music]
yeah okay yeah i like the matching
actually i do too okay we're going to
get some boots oh yeah
it's my origin
by the time you put this vlog up it'll
be your birthday now
i think he needs glasses okay let's see
thank
uh that's freaking cute
yeah okay let's go
we can get the aviators as well but i
think he might be open
he needs prescription
[Music]
so
so this entire trip the one place that i
really wanted to go was i still can't
say it zadig and
vol voltaire voltaire is that right hold
hair
sometimes i struggle with words so we
went there and
a few years ago i think you actually
might remember seeing the vlog if some
of you guys have been around for a while
i bought a camera watch there and my
camera watch broke so my plan was
next time i'm in london
i'm gonna go return
said watch we're on our way to johnny
cupcakes before we go there though i
must show you
look at this freaking bag
it is so bright i'm losing my mind and
i'm showing my watch i'll show you later
because
so the watch is like a colorful
camo i'm in love
johnny cupcakes
we
are almost there
so excited what do i wonder what we're
gonna get we're gonna get like a t-shirt
or two you know t-shirt with a cupcake
on it because we're heading to oh hi no
we're heading to paris tomorrow and then
we're heading to ohio so we've got we've
got some travels ahead of us i would
like a new tea
oh with my white tea oh and my white tea
johnny we're here
we're here we're just gonna miss him too
does he work here yeah he's coming here
in a couple of well in a few days but
we'll already be gone
no
johnny
you're going to take a picture can you
please take a photo francesca's taking
so many pictures for me i'm like
ridiculous i don't care this is like
this is my motto as well
right what makes you happy yeah doing
makeup makes me happy as long as it's
taking naps
do we like the women's
women's cut
or do we like the men's
cut
wait where's here's the women's no no
but it says it says london england
i don't like women's cut clothes okay
sorry i don't like no no no money
[Music]
my favorite thing ever
oh well that brings i think the london
trip to a close we're heading to paris
tomorrow so i'll see you guys
in the next video when we head to paris
mr bear
does not look well i think he looked
better without all of his
army attire
off to paris
[Music]